The sun is the major source of hate and light for every creature on our planet.
It's Ray feed plants warm the ground,
turn glassies into mountain rivers and move our masses around to create a
refreshing breeze. Billions of kilometers away from us.
Other stars give hate to other planets, which are different from our earth,
quite in the same manner,
but there are worlds out there that are completely independent from any star.
Their sky will never beli by sunrise and their surfaces are shrouded
in an eternal night.
Their destined to billions of years of soloists in the cold expanses of the
cosmos and only silver clouds made up of finest ice needles.
As it were hang over the dark horizon,
Outer space.
Assumptions about the existence of space objects, the size of our planet,
which are independent from any star have been around for a long time.
Such celestial objects freely drifting around into Stella space are referred to
as orphan free floating or rogue planets,
astronomical bodies of this kind emit viral little thermal and light energy into
space around them.
It has suggested that there are no bodies in their close proximity they could
clearly interact with or be bound to.
That is why it is hardly surprising that these objects are so difficult to
detect.
The first potential representatives of this class of planets were spotted.
As recently as in the air early 21st century,
the warmest rogue planets can be detected with infrared telescopes and others.
Thanks to something called the gravitational microlensing effect.
As one would expect this class of celestial objects is one of the most
mysterious and understudied today only three astronomical
bodies can be classified as rogue planets with a sufficient degree of certainty
with the overall number of rogue planet candidates over two dozen
incidentally,
according to the analysis of data collected in the course of the Al project,
the milk your way may supposedly be home to up to a hundred billion objects of
this class.
This may only mean that right now,
we're at the very beginning of an upcoming series of discoveries in this field,
our notions of what rogue planets are like have long been based purely on
assumptions and hypotheses with a technological advancement of highly
sensitive observation equipment there,
row opportunities to put them the test in practice,
The rogue planet lying closest to the earth among those already confirmed is
known as wise oh 8 5 5 minus oh
7 14 7 0.27 light years away from the sun.
It was detected in 2014 with a wise orbital infrared telescope,
the astronomical body cannabis seen through optical telescopes as it emits no
visible light to speak of.
The reason for this is its extremely low temperature from
225 to 260 Calvin or 48 to
13 degrees Celsius below zero.
In terms of its parameters,
it resembles a cooled off gas giant and its age can be under a billion years.
The rogue planet is mostly made up of hydrogen. However,
in 2016,
the Gemini observatory produced evidence of the presence of large amounts of
water in its atmosphere. It has suggested that water is condensed into clouds,
made up of tiniest particles of ice today.
It hasn't been established for certain how this object came to be.
There are currently two very suggested by researchers,
according to the first one celestial object like that starts its lifecycle
in the proto planetary disc of a regular planetary system.
Mathematical modeling of this process shows that if the original cloud of gas
and dust is heavy enough,
it is highly likely that at least one planet will be did beyond the system.
The celestial object may also be forced out of its stars. Environ.
If another massive star passes it by or else,
if its planetary system collides with another system,
the chances of events like that are admittedly comparatively small.
The other version has it that the space object was born just like any other star
on compression of Interstella gas. At the same time,
the mass of the object proved to be too small to unleash any Thermo nuclear
reactions in its interior. It goes without saying that in this manner,
it may turn out only as a gas joint or a brown wha but not a Rocky
planet.
Similar to the
some researchers don't agree that these objects should be seen as rogue planets
and classify them as sub brown dwarves. Instead,
others suggest using the term Len Nemo for all inter stellar wanders that
don't show any thermonuclear activity bearing in mind,
today's notions of the up of brown wolves and gas joints,
where may estimate the mass of wise, oh 8 55 minus oh seven 14,
a 10 thing from three to 10 Jupiter masses.
This rather falls short of starting a Thermo nuclear reaction,
but quite enough to keep the heat effectively trapped inside the planet,
taking into count our knowledge about natural laws.
We can predict what the conditions on the astronomical body's surface are like.
For example, according to research by David,
John Stevenson from the university of California in the us gas giants,
similar to Jupiter, don't cool off instantly after receding from their star,
their thick hydrogen atmosphere is quite reliable.
Thermal isolation while the dense and hot nucleus made up of metallic.
Hydrogen can keep the planet heated for a considerable time.
Estimates show that the temperature of the lowest Strater,
a hyper tical celestial objects atmosphere may be high enough for liquid water
to be around.
It is likely to be present in the atmosphere as giant clouds made up of tiniest
droplets.
These deductions agree with the results of mathematical modeling of wise oh
8 55 minus oh seven 14 carried out by a team of S from the univers
of Edinburg.
It showed that the most likely temperature value of the planet's surface is 250
Kelvin or 23 degrees. CELs below zero.
The Celest steel body's atmosphere also has a comparatively warm layer around a
hundred kilometers thick whose density fluctuates from 0.4 to 1.2
milli per cubic centimeter. It is comparable with the conditions on the earth.
And so it is thought that this environment should be favorable for potential
organic life.
Incidentally,
a planet doesn't have to be a massive gas giant to avoid freezing in the cosmos
in 2020,
a rogue planet candidate was detect it using gravitational microlensing
techniques. And here is the long designation. It got,
it is still a waiting confirmation of the rogue planet status and its parameters
have been defined only generally so far, according to preliminary data.
However,
the object is comparable to the earth in terms of its mass and is ING from 30
to 180,000 light years away.
According to our current scientific notions,
an object with a mass like that is not supposed to be a gas giant and is more
likely to be a Rocky planet.
This in its turn offers good grounds to believe that the object formed in the
proto planetary disc of a planetary sit, as the latter was forming,
it may have been ejected from the system as a result of a cataclysmic space or
alternatively onto the influence of a larger neighbor after that it was left to
its own devices.
And so became a free floating planet. What will happen to it?
Next is predefined by a combination of several factors provided the
objects atmosphere is sufficiently dense. It will be reliably,
thermally isolated,
potentially a layer of ice on its surface could produce the same isolating
fact. In addition with the objects interior,
scorching hot and with radioactive elements, undergoing decay,
most of the hypothetical ocean will remain in a liquid state.
If the planet happened to have a moon, it may have retained it on ejection.
If this is the case,
ti forces are likely to continue to deformed and warm up the lithosphere,
theoretically, with any luck primitive,
anaerobic life forms may have stayed around.
Although of course it would be next to impossible to discover their traces. Now,
most of the data about the rogue planets were now today were arrived out
following mathematical modeling and complex calculations. It,
it was possible to do these calculations,
thanks to the tiniest bits of information gleamed with the help of orbital and
earth-based telescopes.
Even as I speak a project is being worked on known as clear Parra.
Its main objective will be to search for free floating planets and other objects
and space. With subsequent definition of their parameters,
the project relies on something called microlensing.
It is a phenomenon when a celestial body passes between a remote star and the
observer on the earth and briefly interferes with the light emit by the remote
star in the background, when observed from different angles,
the moment of transition will be registered a front action of a second sooner in
one observatory than in another referred to as lensing per this
effect allows scientists to gauge the distance to detected object as well as its
mass and dimensions and interplanetary spacecraft is plant to be created
within the project.
It is supposed to blast off the surface of the earth as soon as in 2025,
alongside a mission to Mars after which it will enter its own orbit around
the sun.
The project will be aided by a specialized artificial intelligence component
whose mission will be to process and analyze collected information.
The Clara project will certainly delight us with a of exciting and important
information. So there is a lot to look forward to
what is to become of all those rogue worlds out there,
drifting quite by themselves in the dark depths of the universe.
In theory,
an orphan planet may be captured by the gravitational field of a star and be
come part of its planetary system. But this chance is by all accounts,
minuscule,
most objects like that are destined to wonder for billions of years through
endless expanses of space while slowly and inevitably cooling off,
eventually there to be swallowed up by black holes or else destroyed
as a result of a cataly space, never to reveal their secrets to mankind.